a welcome home for one of america's most
famous and famously disgraced men
more than 60 women have accused bill
cosby of offenses against them
but now 83 he is on a technicality a
free man
appearing outside home with his lawyers
andrew drove cosby home from the prison
inmates started knocking on the walls
you're free you're free
but as i was driving him and i was
recording him
as he was talking in the car he said
andrew my heart is racing
he said not in a bad way but in the most
amazing way
cosby was known as america's dad because
of his
friendly brand of comedy but he became
the first celebrity tried and convicted
in the metoo era how you feeling this
morning bill
he was found guilty of drugging and
molesting this woman
andrea constand
guilty jody guilty
this was the reaction afterwards
but now pennsylvania's supreme court
ruled that conviction be overturned
because five women testified against him
despite
their cases being passed the statute of
limitation
he'd also made a deal with a previous
prosecutor that he would never face
criminal charges
bill cosby and his wife are inside their
home here in elkins park pennsylvania
celebrating his first night of freedom
in almost
three years but this is a case that will
divide
america
this man believes it's justice for black
america
this woman believes it's a miscarriage
of justice for his alleged victims
such a punch in the gut after all of
these years of victims
and their advocates people like me
trying to move the ball
forward and get justice against bill
cosby more than
60 women have accused him and now to
have his criminal conviction
reversed and have him walk out of court
a free man
on what i consider to be a real
technicality
cosby has always maintained his
innocence and cannot now be retried
a legal battle won but not so in the
court of public opinion
martha kellner sky news pennsylvania